the first problem with people going
sober is that alcohol is the only drug
where if you don't do it people assume
you have a problem there is a branding
issue with sobriety in that the only
people that don't drink are presumed to
be closeted alcoholics and I get
messages from people who haven't seen
the history of my content and then
they'll just come upon a post and it
says I'm 10 months sober I'm a team on
some 20 months sober whatever it might
be
congratulations so much I have to say I
loved a a I thought that the support
there was great and I'm like ah I feel
like an impostor like I thank you for
congratulating me but being honest I've
never had a problem with substances oh
okay why what's the reason it's just a
productivity tool the same way as people
decide to focus on their sleep or their
nutrition or their training or whatever
it is I just know the tools everyone
bankable radio what is happening as is
the theme with a lot of these podcasts
during this lockdown period we're kind
of ignoring it like it's just happening
but just you know to pretend it's not
there let's just let's just look to move
forward let's look to improve areas of
our lives that we can let's look to muse
and we will be doing that today there's
not many guests that was returned to the
show there's probably been about six
over the years that have returned to the
show but I was watching Chris I was
watching his Instagram stories the other
day and he was talking about a topic
I've been thinking about a lot about
recently it's been covered in the news
quite a bit because obviously people are
locked at home and what's now happening
is our kind of habits our beliefs our
environments they've kind of compound it
they've intensified because we're at
home and whether that's a positive or a
negative thing it's either become more
positive or more negative and I thought
the topic of alcohol and our
relationship with it was something that
I wanted to go further down the rabbit
hole with and on the first episode of
this show with Chris we talked about it
we only really spent about ten minutes
on it and having watched Chris's
Instagram story no it was just a post on
Instagram I think I was like yes
let's go there Chris get back on the
show so Chris Williamson welcome back to
the show great animate doubled up to
over so it's what can I say yeah man
absolute pleasure to be back on and
looking forward to talking about
something that I spend a lot of time
thinking about so yeah let's get into it
why do you continue to think about it I
think that a lot of people's alcohol use
is habituated rather than chosen that's
the bottom line
I think most people drink because other
people did and then they started to just
societal norm and then we roll the clock
forward by 5 years or 10 years or 15
years or 20 years and you've taken a
drug to call it what it is alcohol is a
drug you've taken a drug more frequently
than once every fortnight for decades
like if you if you just arrived on earth
and were like what's some of the rules
about how you operate as a human so
maybe in civilization comes down here in
the UFO and so oh is this and you doing
this that you do and you don't walk on
your feet and you do this gravity and
all this sort of then you go oh yeah by
the way does this drug that you take and
you kind of you kind of not force to
take it it will shorten your life also
gives you memory loss it also it makes
you fat also it makes you want to eat
and it makes you feel like depressed and
terrible the next day but you're gonna
you're gonna have it more than you're
gonna choose to have it more than once
every two weeks and then yeah I mean
look at what's happened with lockdown
man there's the biggest uproar in
America one of the biggest dope rods in
America was when the government
threatened to make off licenses at
liquor stores they'd call them
non-essential and shut them down and
there was people hoarding alcohol what
does that tell us it tells us that
people struggle to get through hard
times without the butchers the
scaffolding that is alcohol so I think
about it a lot and then I have six
months sober calm which is an online
course I made to help guide people that
just want to deprogram the use of
alcohol not for people that have
substance abuse problems but just for
people who want to
use the foundation of consistency that
sobriety gives you to then build
yourself and improve yourself and I'm
you know I'm 20 months sober as of last
week and I just it's so bizarre that
going Sobers got an addictive essence to
it because you see the consistency you
have you have more time you have more
money you have more calories to spend on
things that you truly care about and
then you realize that when you choose to
reintegrate drinking if you choose to
reintegrate drinking that it's on your
terms know that you are in full control
because you've deprogrammed the need to
feel worried that you can't you can go
on a night out with your buddies and
then say why are you not drinking or
you've deprogrammed the need to feel
like you need alcohol to give you
confidence to go up and talk to that
girl or that guy or to just be in a
group or because you taste buds have
become accustomed to having like and
you're a sparkly more fun on you as you
talk about spot yeah so you know to just
be able to get away with a Lacroix or
whatever it might be a some Pellegrino
or ever at the table instead of getting
a bottle of wine in so you do all this
deprogramming and you realize hang on
I'm actually now re-released into the
world and I've got full control as
opposed to thinking I've got control
right so yeah that's it man that's
foundation base that's what we're
talking about so before we go on and go
down a couple of rabbit holes let's do a
quick elevator pitch some people have
not listened to my show before some
people might not know who you are
what is the Chris Williamson elevator
pitch oh okay business owner from
newcastle club promoter run nightclubs
for 13 years I've seen a million drunk
people go in and out of them so I
understand how alcohol works I
understand what party life is for a very
long time was the party boy I was the
[ __ ] club promoter the guy around
town big dick on campus all this stuff
did take me out got to go to Fernando's
and meet paddy McGuinness great did look
Island got to meet Caroline Flack and go
to the villa
also great fantastic bluetick on twitter
you know all of all the big things big
headlines then started modern wisdom
which is my podcast site that two and a
half years ago just cross two million
downloads which is fantastic aided in a
big way by yourself giving me a platform
early on while we were doing that and
drove a lot of plays off the back of
that so I have a lot to thank you for in
that many and then that's it man I just
I'm curious as [ __ ] like I just I just
want to know about everything I'm super
super curious and that has led me I've
got a desire with performance and
productivity and optimising as well not
super like quantified self stuff but you
know I like to get better and I like it
I have a growth mindset and that just
meant I stopped playing around with
loads of different things loads of
different ways to improve my life with
intermittent fasting in different ways
of changing his sleep up and all this
sort of things I'm one of the most
effective things that I found was going
sober despite the fact that I was a very
infrequent drinker I still found huge
gains from it and I guess that's the
route into how sobriety came in there
but yeah that's it and we're now on the
13th floor and you can step out onto
Europe on a veranda or wherever we are
in this elevator so you bring up an
interesting topic there cuz I I've just
started talking to a therapist again and
I went to this therapist and said I
don't have a problem I'm not in pain I
don't need anything primarily like
solving but right now I feel like I'm in
a really good place with everything my
body my mind my business and really
balanced and you know I'm really happy
and I get that I'm very fortunate for a
couple of reasons due to that and I
don't want to kind of deliberate on that
because we're in lockdown and I live in
the countryside I'm not in a stuffy flat
and all these things but I've worked
hard in my opinion on my mental game to
be really content with wherever I am in
life so in since therapists and I
started chatting to her and I said I'm
here because I want to understand if I
actually know my truth and it's not any
element of my ego sort of disguising my
own wisdom I almost want you to like
catch me out and as we were talking
through these different layers we start
to talk about our character traits and I
resonate with you because I think we're
quite similar we love exploring the mind
we just love personal
there was a point in the conversation
where it's almost like you become you
try and aim to become so pure and so
understood and so balanced and so for
consistent that do you lose yourself in
it and that do you forget to relax and
have fun and chill out and because my
therapist used an example that she loves
to be really organized and I do as well
and it's like we were almost joking
about how we like to organize our
downtime and I just said - I was like do
I am I forgetting how to relax like do i
and it was really interesting so hearing
you talk about you just being like fully
in control and immersed in having a
routine how does that narrative sit -
you feel like you're living every sense
of kind of your life in in all this kind
of optimization that is almost are you
standing back enough to just sort of be
present I don't know does that do you
get where I'm going I totally understand
your question man I think the first
thing for anyone that's new or
experienced to the self development
world to appreciate is that there's
layers to this game you know there is
certain it is an onion and unfortunately
it's an endless onion you peel away some
persona you get rid of so you strip away
some ego and he'll I guess yes that's
that's it that's me I'm at the core I
hang on and you realize and the way to
work this out is do you think that you
12 to 24 months ago on balance was
actually a little bit of an idiot and
always always that's the case you're
like [ __ ] what I thought I had it
figured out I thought I had it figured
out two years ago and look what's
happened I'm still up still good you
know I didn't know anything it's like in
two years time you're gonna look back at
the person that you are now and you're
gonna say the same thing which is both a
blessing and a curse because if you're
constantly growing inevitably you're
going to leave old versions of yourself
behind right and the way that our lives
work as well as epochs of our life these
kind of like maybe between two and five
years segments I think that we move
through where we could bunch together
a common story you know like a theme
that that that two to five years has got
and then it's okay and then I wanted
this but I don't wonder this button I
wonder this bit and that's real typical
right so that's the first thing um
second thing there's this quote from
ancient philosopher I'm gonna see if
I've got down here for you let me see if
I can find you this I'm reading one of
the best articles that I've ever read at
the moment and what they talk about is
how spontaneity is actually created
through discipline in the beginning
right and that sounds that sounds a
little bit bizarre
you know what hang hang on a spontaneity
and discipline to me are two different
things like how can you have a situation
where you hope you have a situation
where you have a very structured life
and you are constantly I know how much
I'm gonna eat I know what time we're
gonna wake up I've got my morning
routine and my evening routine in my
work routine and this is how my desk set
and all the rest of this stuff and um
how can I allow that how does that mix
in with other things and there's this
rule way there it is so there's a quote
from and this is a guy called Kyle Ann
Schroeder who wrote the article and it's
so good so in the early stages of
training an aspiring Confucian gentleman
needs to memorize entire shelves of
archaic texts learn the precise angle at
which to bow and learn the lengths of
steps with which he is to enter the room
his sitting map must also always be
perfectly straight all of this rigor and
restraint however is ultimately aimed at
producing a cultivated but nonetheless
genuine form of spontaneity indeed the
process of training is not considered
complete until the individual has passed
completely beyond the need for thought
or effort and this ties in with the way
that the brain works as well anybody
that's read Thinking Fast and Slow by
Daniel Kahneman knows this you've got
the instinctive response which is you
system-1 and then you've got the slower
more considered response which is number
two
now what you need to do and what a lot
of routines do is they actually pull you
out of the first type of thinking they
pull you out of that they stop you from
having just the visceral response the
instinctive response you become more
considered and yet you have to go
through sometimes an almost lifelong
period of discipline but as that slowly
reintegrates what you realize is that
the discipline has become your nature so
the fact that you want to be more
grateful so you have to practice
gratitude every single morning that
three or four years and then over time
you're actually that hang in a second
I'm being grateful here in exactly the
same way as I want to be a little bit
more muscular so you start doing weight
training and at the beginning you don't
have muscles and over time you're still
true doing the training and yet your
muscles are there to stay that makes
sense and that that kind of move between
the two by I totally get what you mean
man that it feels like discipline can be
a bit of a burden and for a lot of
people it is but I think that's more a
problem to do with the way that were
brought into this world like school so
the word school is an ancient Greek word
that means play it doesn't mean
education it doesn't mean place of you
know like discipline it means play and
yet when you go to school you think I've
got to go to school and I get to go to
school and all this austere so I think
discipline and the way that we get
socialized into that is a big part of it
right and a lot of people shy away from
you know their time off the weekends are
you know I'll just sleep in till 10:00
o'clock and I'll do whatever I want and
the Sun you know that's totally sweet
but long-term over time if you are
disciplined you're actually oddly enough
end up liberating yourself
so with all that being said this is one
of my pet hates with many people's
relationship of Technology and alcohol
all tie into this different level as
well but because we're so connected I
feel that every front kind of jumbles
through each other there's like there's
these energies and identities that are
constantly mixing and I've speaking to
my kind of therapist and we were
identifying layers of my character and
how I wanted to behave in my business
life my personal life and I remember
listening to an interview with an
Middleton don't know if you've ever
spoken to an Middleton no I had a Leo
Layton on last week so his
second-in-command to hunt but yeah and
Santa baddest he's legit nice
so I met an at the UK fitness Awards and
I've had a little chat with him great
guy and then I listened to him on
another podcast and he he gave some
really polarizing opinions and there's a
couple of things like I kind of
disagreed with and I was like I can't
disagree because I don't know enough
context so I downloaded this book at the
beginning of the weekend and I've
started racing through his audiobook
which is brilliant because I love like
war stories because it's always like
it's stuff that we like what I'll say is
mortals never get to experience we're
not [ __ ] soldiers like so I love
listening to that kind of stuff in any
way he talks about all these layers of
everyone's identity and most men will
have a problem going from work dude to
lead a dude to work out dude
- dad dude - husband dude because it's
all getting muddied of this
interconnectedness and I thought it was
really good for me because when I look
at my life I want to turn up in a
certain way - every environment and I
think you know what we're getting at
with one into develop ourselves is like
when you and I go to work we want to be
a certain person and we want to turn up
for those five six seven eight hours as
a certain person but as soon as you walk
through the door at home we want to be a
slightly different person but actually
all of that sometimes gets lost and I
never think that I
people struggle to live that kind of
true self in every environment and
perhaps that's the beauty of all of this
is developing yourself that you can live
to your truest best identity in any
given environment yeah I couldn't agree
more man I mean there's people that you
know that are argumentative at work and
they'll be argumentative at home you
know there's certain themes that go
through people's lives
again with this there's another this is
a Seneca quote that he talked about the
virtuous mean which is not advice of
deficiency nor a vice of excess I think
one of the reasons why people like to go
all in in like work mode and athlete
mode and dad mode and all the rest of it
is that the same reason it's easier to
finish an entire packet of biscuits than
it is to just eat one it's like I'm good
at black-and-white it's gray area
thinking where you have to do a little
bit but not too much so I need to be a
bit of a disciplinarian with my kids but
I also need to give them a bit of love
and I also at work I need to care about
people I need to get them to buy into me
but also I got to treat them as if they
are in one way or another little bit
children and then with the wife I also
need to make sure that we're living and
caring but I also need to stand my own
ground you know all these different
things it's challenging that's why life
is real difficult and this is why for me
huge bizarrely like a huge respect to
the people who don't bother to delve
into the world of self-development
because they're living you know by and
large from the outside just as effective
a life as anybody else but then that's
totally my business partner Darren like
he'll pick up some of the stuff that I
say from the podcast but he doesn't care
man he's got two kids two dogs beautiful
wife beautiful house and he operates
fine you know like he functions
completely completely great but I do
think you know there's things that all
of us can improve on here and there and
I think being true to yourself as you've
mentioned a number of times you know
enacting your logos as Jordan Peterson
would say what is your inner truth and
how are you speaking it forward into the
world that's what we should be trying to
achieve where we can sorry that was a
little tangent and we did start off
talking about alcohol itself back into
alcohol hopefully
a few of those things have made us
thinking on the old gray matter already
so with alcohol the first show that we
kind of talked about we talked about the
reasons why you've done it and what it
led to clearer thinking better routine
not getting a groggy head all the kind
of stuff that anyone would experience if
they stopped taking alcohol for a week
you just you feel a bit better over time
when you challenge people online what is
quite often the roadblocks for people
actually committing to what you're
saying almost what are they scared of
the first problem with people going
sober is that alcohol is the only drug
where if you don't do it people assume
you have a problem there's a branding
issue there is a branding issue with
sobriety in that the only people that
don't drink are presumed to be closeted
alcoholics and I get messages from
people who haven't seen lots of my
back-end content or like a history of my
content and then they'll just come upon
a post that's maybe appeared on the
newsfeed and it says I'm 10 months sober
I'm 18 months I'm 20 months or whatever
it might be
congratulations so much I have to say I
loved a a I thought that the support
there was great and I'm like ah I feel
like an impostor like I appreciate that
I thank you for congratulating me but
being honest I've never had a problem
with substances oh okay
why what's the reason it's just a
productivity tool the same way as people
decide to focus on the sleep or the
nutrition or their training or whatever
it is I took alcohol out of my life is
you might reduce processed foods or you
might take out carbs you might go keto
you know like it's just a it's just
another tool so challenges that people
come up against number one is social
employees so they don't want to feel
like their friends are gonna take the
piss out of them because they're not
drinking again
no going sober this is kind of this boy
club playful even for girls this like
quite boys club playful what are may go
on just awkward what do you people make
up excuses people have got the car it's
like you've only driven so you can say
that you don't have to drink because
like having the car is one of the few
acceptable it like that be
pregnant are the only two acceptable
excuses about why you're not drinking
you know so social pressures big deals
of people right
butcher Singh of confidence is another
one either in groups especially if
you're single you know especially if
you're single and especially if you're a
bloke that's single because there's a
guy you were expected to be the sexual
protagonist right you're expected to go
up to to the girls if they're really
girls
listening who are the ones that start
off these conversations in bars and
clubs and it doesn't count if you get
your friend to go up on your behalf or
if you're the friend that's not how it
works but if you're one of the girls
that goes up and says like I think they
are really good-looking all right you
sing a lot hi what's your name would you
like a drink or any of that you are a
very unique individual because for the
most part its men right so men use that
Dutch courage everyone knows what that's
like after that there's the midweek
drinker so you would have someone who
has stresses at work they would use
their alcohol to deal with that and that
concern would be well if alcohols my
coping mechanism and it allows me I just
want to relax you know it just helped me
relax on a night they would never say
coping mechanism they would just say you
know it just helps me relax after I've
had it anything that's a coping
mechanism that's what that's the that's
it by definition some people would use
it to help themselves sleep on a night
that is just a complete non sequitur
because you're not sleeping you're just
sedated the research that comes out from
Matthew Walker's book why we sleep is
pretty robust on that where he says the
reason that you have crazy dreams when
you've been drinking a lot is because
your REM sleep hasn't been able to begin
until all of the alcohols been processed
out of your system that's why I like the
last couple of hours maybe of a night
when you've had a few drinks is where
you have mad dreams because your bodies
your brains can try to condense all of
that down right so that's that's some of
the big ones I mean there's tons of
other things right there's like so let
before we go down more rabbit holes will
give more reasons I'm fascinated by the
first point because that's obviously a
problem for a huge amount of people
because a lot of us have certain friend
groups and if the friend groups always
drink and you don't drink and friend
group dynamic becomes different
difficult and you become maybe quickly
the out car so like when you've worked
with people what generally happens does
the person almost think I'm not sure if
these people some of these people could
be my friends anymore because it's like
we just go out and drink but then
there's a confidence issue because then
where does that person sort of almost
get their confidence from and I suppose
it's like anything wants you on when you
reveal in a layer of that onion it's
like well now we need to go to the next
layer because you're not actually
confidence and now we need to work on
your confidence you don't need the
alcohol in a social situation or with
girls or with family or with anything
mmm yeah well I mean I've got a quote
from James clear here that I've just
pulled up changing your habits often
requires you to change your tribe each
tribe has a set of shared expectations
behaviors that conform to the shared
expectations are attractive behaviors
that conflict with the shared
expectations are unattractive it's hard
to go against the group so that their
shows why we aren't with tribal
creatures you know there's them and us
that's why football teams and football
supporters get so that's why my world
wars are started you know that's why
there's rivalry between different
political factions or religious factions
or whatever it might be so you're right
the first the first problem is going to
be you're around a bunch of people who
are used to you drinking but the the way
the people that I've worked with a lot
of the clients have dealt with it is by
finding the friends who they can bear to
be around sober and this is a really
challenging thing to realize right how
many of the friends that you have do you
only spend time with when you drink and
then think from that group how many of
them could you bear to be around without
alcohol
like if the only time that your friends
are happy with you being with them is
when you're destroying yourself along
with them then you need better friends
and if you find out that the only way
you can bear to be around them is by
being drunk okay and you definitely need
better friends you know like be friends
with people that want the best for you
people that don't not just ones that
[ __ ] take the path of least
resistance people that just tell you
what you want to hear like the point is
to be with people who raise you up who
make you better and if you say hey I'm
gonna I'm doing this six months sober
challenge thing I'm gonna do that 90
days I'm gonna try go so within 90 days
they don't just go off [ __ ] tell me
why are you [ __ ] I know like be with
the people who go all right well I mean
you know you're gonna be a bit bit more
boring than a night out but that's cool
like it'll be sweet to see how you get
on and I really hope that you do well
and this that knew that and again with
that like as you domain if competence
grows and this is something that's so
insidious man and this is why people
people need to strip away the ego
because you can influence someone really
negatively if you if you're not careful
right so that person your one friend of
you that you've come to me and you've
said hey Chris I'm thinking about going
sober and I'm the guy that goes that
sounds totally [ __ ] like why would you
bother doing night it's Jono's
thirty-third next week you can't miss
out on John OHS 33rd 32nd was [ __ ]
wank like why would I be bothered about
his 33rd so you you know you've got that
and not this person than me they like
[ __ ] version of me that I've just
given you there that could be the
barrier that stops you that creates
inertia that stops you from making a
really important piece of behavior
change in your life that would upgrade
you make you happy or make you healthy
and give you my money and time and
calories to spend on share you care
about like that's you know you can be
that influence in people's lives it
doesn't take much to actually be a real
positive influence so when people decide
to go sober they need to look at who are
the people in the group that support
them you know as opposed to someone who
says that's totally [ __ ] what about the
friend that goes actually made like
would you drink and I could like do it
as well direct and we could do it
together and would like the
accountability buddies or whatever how
amazing would that be you know those are
the people who
your best interests at heart the ones
that want that and the the final point
on this is and this it goes for all
behavior change also goes for again
especially a little bit more so with
guys because they tend to be quite
territorial but as your domain of
competence grows as a guy or a girl your
domain of competence grows and you start
to improve yourself you're going to hold
a very very harsh mirror up to the bad
habits of the people that are around you
and that can cause those people to start
to lash out they can start to say things
because your improvement and your
progression makes them feel incredibly
self-conscious incredibly worthless
because you're pulling ahead you know
that hang on a second we were we
finished uni at the same time but you
won't how come you bought a house at 26
our well mates because I've got a car on
PCP that cost a grand a month for the
last four years or whatever it might be
you know or why you lis no it's because
I went to the gym as opposed to just
going out and having to take away every
night or pick whatever domain it is but
especially with alcohol because it's
inherently so social well as you start
to move away from people like that they
can start to lash out and they'll
purposefully you know with behaviors
that go against the tribe kind of
punished they'll start to push you out
but do you want to be friends with those
sorts of people like the answer is no
and so many friendship groups have just
grandfathered in that these like
artifacts of a time gone by ah well you
know it's when I used to play rugby
bro you haven't played rugby in a decade
like what are you on about like the only
thing that you and these people have in
common is the fact that you once did a
thing forever ago and all that you now
talk about is that thing you did forever
ago that's totally fine if you want to
live a life that's stuck in the past but
if you want to live a life that's
constantly moving forward then allow the
waste men and the waste chicks that
you've accumulated along the way allow
them to fall away and again as you go
sober as you do any behavior change
start eating more healthily go to the
gym do whatever it is that you start to
do but specifically with alcohol as you
go sober you will start to see the world
for what it is and this is why I keep on
referring to going sober
taking the ultimate red pill like that
you stopped seeing matrix and you start
seeing code and you realize hang on a
second
that guy is actually really really
negative or that girl is actually really
really bad for me or that person always
really negative because you start to see
the world with clear eyes for the first
time you don't it's not nerfed by
alcohol and all your inhibitions going
out the window you know hmm well that is
quite often one of the hardest elements
of change is looking at your environment
and having to sort of potentially slowly
we move away from friendship groups and
I've done it loads I left uni while I
left school and probably had two friends
once I left schools I changed an awful
lot from school when I left uni what was
the what was the big change were the big
first changes that I was the obese fat
acting lad at school and then I became
the fit guide that lost five and a half
stone it became a personal trainer so I
completely shifted identity and changed
my life so didn't know those people
anymore they didn't know me then when I
left uni probably left uni with like
five or six people that you keep in
touch with but you need not bazillions
of friends but all of those friends are
transient sports teams clubs all the
rest of it and I think that's quite
often the beautiful thing of life that
friends come and go experiences happen
and they go and I you know if you have
five best friends in your life but
there's nothing wrong with that well you
don't have to have a best friend for 50
years but you can do I'm not saying
that's a bad thing yeah but there's
nothing wrong with having you know five
different best friends as you evolve
through life and you're interested in
different things and you have kids and
all that kind of stuff
I think that's fearful for some people
was there's probably a level of
self-worth there to say well what if I
don't find a new best friend well who
don't find anybody to go you know to the
pub with or whatever it's almost like
and if I leave that friend well another
one come well it's a scarcity mindset
right as opposed to an abundance mindset
and I totally get it right being on your
own is a challenge and I have a extra
amount of sympathy for the people that
are listening who are in lockdown der
extroverts now I'm so fortunate
now to be an introvert because to me
I've been socially distancing for 32
years I've been practicing since the day
I was born
but I appreciate and I've had a lot of
messages from people who are saying man
I'm struggling with the lack of social
connection here like this is this is
really challenging and to you my heart
goes out some easy hacks FaceTime people
more do Skype calls more make sure that
you're organizing like consistent chats
with people all the time to give you
that sense of that semblance of like
being with people and stuff like that
but on the flip side of that as well
like extroverts have an unfair advantage
every other period of life there isn't a
pandemic lock down because you get to
network more easily and you tend to go
out more and socialize more and stuff
like that so this is this is a little
bit of repayment for that but yeah man a
people hold on the friendships you know
they hold on the friendships are so bad
for them and I think I think questioning
that like why these people in my life
you know like being taking a minimalist
approach is someone might-- with their
possessions to their friendships because
like two bad friendships is worse than
it is is very very bad like two bad
friendships where you've got two people
who are impacting you negatively that is
like leading you astray
maybe maybe you've got a bunch of
buddies who are still party party boys
maybe you get towards like your late 20s
or your early thirties or whatever and
these guys are still weekend warriors
they're still getting a couple of bags
in on a weekend and all right mate let's
go we're good the dock house in Leeds
this weekend like such-and-such your
DJ's playing or whatever it might be and
you're like yeah bro like you know that
was fun when we were 22 but you know I
kind of I kind of actually want to try
and find a missus and settle down now I
really actually want to try and find a
boyfriend who I could move in well
whatever it might be right
like people are scared to believe in
those people behind you it's like what's
out there for me it's like this [ __ ]
tons of people are out there for you
it's just a case of letting go of the
ones that you don't need anymore
so when we were chatting on whatsapp
before this podcast we talked about what
I felt my relationship with alcohol was
before this talked about alcohol in its
broadest sense and how people sort of
use it generally escape his own and I
think escapism is something that I want
to make sure we include in today's show
too I think that's a fascinating topic
and I don't know what level of escapism
is healthy because I think sometimes
everyone wants to experience things out
of their own body to an extent it's
almost a little bit fun so my
relationship of alcohol probably have
between three and five to six drinks a
week and I sort of said to you you know
I think it's a healthy relationship how
about one can of beer is quite often
like before meal with a meal with the
missus never have more than two drinks
because I just hate feeling tired the
next day don't not down with any of that
they want it to affect my performance
and you were like oh cool I want to ask
you a couple of questions about that
because obviously anyone's relationship
with anything is
how they want to deal and manage their
own life at any given time I don't think
my alcohol relationship has changed
we've locked down make sure you've been
exactly the same like I didn't have a
beer last night but had a beer the night
before now a glass of champagne with my
wife the night before that okay so why
why did you have them
why'd you have the beer so tell me tell
me why you had the beer first yeah sure
so my three reasons are absolutely love
sort of craft beer so I never drink the
same bit I always drink a different beer
from a different part of the world all
different sours stouts IPAs nippers all
these some of your what some of your
pigs what some of your favorites that
you've had recently oh Jesus
a lot favorites it's hard when you have
a different one every day I was gonna
say well you're gonna have to remote you
and you get to see them once and then
it's in the bin yeah but I literally
where are you getting in from have you
got like is it like a service of some
kind of subscription service are you
just going online and searching like
cool IPAs calm or something yeah
subscribe to a company called b-52 and
they certain 12 beers every month with
the magazine the magazines what about
the craft beer movement and how its
evolved in and my brother got me into it
and before that I drunk shitty larva
like everyone else and then he opened up
my eyes and I was like me and it's like
good wine I start to enjoy the
complexity of it so I really enjoy just
having a beer like an exploring beer as
a as a thing I love the taste love
bitter tastes my same way as somebody
that somebody might really enjoy
different types of meats or different
types of chocolates or whatever it might
be yeah I get it man okay so you had
that and then why did you have the
champagne what was the reason for the
champagne me and the wife wanted to
celebrate our daughter being four weeks
old woohoo exactly yes that's oh I mean
that that is that is a pretty good
reason so you know I think
and since our discussion last year where
you talked about this as well I think
you have a very it seems very balanced
relationship with alcohol I don't think
that there's anything other than the
inherent enjoyment of the taste and
based on what you've said not the
being the reason you have it right so
second reason yep
you know when you use to have sort of
afternoon drinking you'd go out no you
just get a little bit loose have a bit
of fun but you don't really affect the
next day so I might sort of half an hour
quite often to myself especially now it
would be 5:30 I'm about to cook dinner
crack open a beer
put on some loud tunes and I literally
dance around the kitchen and surround
the kitchen well ever so slightly tipsy
CH there's only one beer you know I
don't drink a lot these days
and it's kind of like I get a chance to
just feel a little bit loose a little
bit like but then you sit down for
dinner have a normal conversation and
yeah it's not really sober by a p.m. or
whatever yeah yeah so it's kind of like
this like half an hour of escapism like
pure relaxation and I dance around the
kitchen and you know when you sort of
challenged me on whatsapp you didn't
challenge me but I knew you were gonna
challenge me so in my head I was already
challenging myself I was like but why
not it's fun didn't have any negative
side effects I enjoyed it
didn't cost a lot didn't damage anyone
put a smile on my face and I was like I
was trying to pick apart the habit so
yet do with that what you made us - and
then what's number three or it was that
number three there - you recent cocaine
um okay so first off you're one of the
most challenging people to convince to
go sober because your relationship with
alcohol is not destructive and also
you're very cognizant about the reasons
of why you drink first off I would say
that you're an outlier in terms of the
way that people have a relationship with
alcohol I would wager that a lot of the
people that are listening will drink
more more frequently with less control
and more regrets than you do so anyone
that's had a hangover within the last
month that well actually it's protein
probably about two out giving they're in
lockdown but anyone that has hangups
consistency consistently where they
think to themselves oh god this sucks
you are choosing for that to happen
there is an asymmetry with drinking
right okay I'll get back to you in a
second I'm coming for you in a second
bed but I'm gonna get the people that
are listening for
there's an asymmetry with drinking right
and you get exponentially increasing
suffering the more that you drink and
you get diminishing returns of enjoyment
the more that you drink so if you have
five drinks right and then you double
that to ten you don't have double the
fun as you had when you had five but you
have more than double the hangover that
makes sense
yeah so the curve of one of them goes up
like that in the curve of the other one
goes down like that that my friend is
called a [ __ ] losing position if you
were a trader and you knew that every
trade that you were gonna put on was
gonna make a loss so that's what it is
he's a loss right you would be very
bankrupt very fast and people that drink
heavily and consistently especially the
ones that aren't doing it consciously
cognizant about it you're doing that
with your health you're doing that with
your health you're doing that with your
consistent consistency within life your
routine your structure mindset all that
stuff right now I'm coming for you
coming back to you so again very
balanced which I like the few remaining
arguments that I've got one of them is
from health ok so there's a study from
The Lancet and it's this the largest
comorbidity study of alcohol that's ever
been to and there may be a new one by
now this is back in 2017 2018 and
alcohol was found to be the single
largest influence on non
disability-adjusted life years for
people under the age of 40 what that
means is that every drink you have
brings you closer to death at the very
best it keeps you like the same length
there's a lot of people like wives tales
back in the day of to housing around Wow
there's resveratrol in the red grapes
that come in to red wine so actually
it's its life lengthening there is some
resveratrol in there there are also some
other antioxidants and things like that
however that is offset and more by the
increased cancer risk and this is done
in a study that covered over a hundred
territories covered over becoming
millions of people over years and years
and years super long form study right
massive absolutely massive and anyone
just search the land set LA and CET
alcohol and the numbers are scary man so
you have to consider am I prepared to
shorten my life by however much it's
going to be you don't know how much it's
going to be am i prepared it's short my
life for the price to pay the price I'm
shorting my life for the profit of of
having this piece that's first one
second one is
if you decide to go solo in a world
which is telling you to drink in a
society which has completely embraced
the norm of drinking and alcohol is not
even seen as a drug and going Sobers
seen as something that's done by people
who have substance addiction problems if
you are able to go sober in that world
for an extended period of time and stay
disciplined the deck of cards starts to
tumble after that for other behavior
change challenges that you come up
against because if you can go sober what
else can't you do you can literally do
anything that you want because going
sober is very challenging now it's less
challenging than people believe it's a
lot less challenging than people believe
actually especially once you get going
same as anything the most hard most
difficult bit about behavior change is
getting over the inertia at the
beginning it's deprogramming all of the
existing structures but once you start
to do it you actually think like if you
can go sober for six months right as a
young guy or girl in fact just isn't any
guy or girl you can go sober for six
months what else can't you do there's
not much more in terms of behavior
change that people would think is harder
than that ah I need to stop cracking my
knuckles I need to stop having like a
piece of chocolate on a night sack bro
you went sober for half a year when the
entire planet drinks alcohol how many
people do you think have gone sober for
half a year like in the Western typical
Western world normal people normal
physiology you're talking single-digit
percents of people who go sober at all
for more than six months in their entire
adult life so that puts you so much
further ahead right so that's that's the
second thing first thing what was the
first thing I remember my first thing
help help the Nanosuit report yes
thank you second thing as we've just
gone through there what was that one
just what else can you achieve yeah
deck of cards third thing was
thing I hope you're not going to ask me
about action city yeah I haven't said it
yet no what was the third ah that was
eight that was it right okay so two
different iterations of the universe so
we've got um rates caffeine caffeine
levels just dipped below where it needs
to be you know I just need someone to
run in with a IV um so two different
iterations of the universe right got Ben
[ __ ] burn in universe one you got Ben
coumarine University everything else is
the same
Ben Cumbre universe one continues to
drink Thank You marina University two
stops drinking what is the difference
six months 12 months down the line
between these two people now the main
question that you need to ask yourself
like let's forget the stuff about health
let's forget the stuff about the
behavior change because that's quite a
long term right if you say if I asked
you this question to listens at home
might consider it as well like what
would happen if you weren't sober for
six months what would happen if you
drank three nights a week for six months
or two nights a week for six months
where would you be where would you be
financially health-wise mindset friends
you know wait all that sort of stuff why
would you be in six months time why
would you be into all this time what's
the difference between those two and if
you can see if it makes you first off if
it's making you feel uncomfortable that
I'm saying this to you then you really
really need to consider what your
relationship with alcohol is like
because the reason that you're feeling
uncomfortable the reason you've got that
visceral response in your stomach and it
makes you feel are [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
love island prick what's he on about
like that's because you know that the
real truth is that you would be a better
version of you in six months time if you
stopped drinking a map you can then
layer back on
okay let's compound this down the line
how much better would my approach my
belief in behavior change be how much
more could I achieve in the future I
have more time money and calories to
spend on things that I truly care about
now those are almost all of people's
problems the 21st century come from
either too much or a lack of those three
things time money and calories that's
what I refer to in six months sober is
the key three is the key three benefits
of
consistency is another one but I didn't
want to call it core 4 because someone's
someone's already trademark done but
you've got these things right it's like
look what would the difference be
between those two so I'll ask you like
do you think that there would be a
marked difference in the way that you
operate in six months time if you
decided to cut out the 12 to 24 beers
come on I mean you know you'll know
what's the beers are the beers that
you'll be having they'll probably be
what three hundred Cal's maybe three to
four hundred cows each unless they're a
stubby now there any a small can
salaries okay okay so it's not tons so
yeah that's a mini but it's all the same
some Magnum mini bro I tell you what
Magnum mini is good okay you know I mean
like you can see that right what's
where's where's the difference on is
there a noticeable difference between
those two bends
I will go deeper into that but I don't
think so so financially not an issue my
beer box is like 32 quid a month I'm
happy with that like whatever socially
wouldn't change a lot of people in my
family that don't drink there's people
my family they do drink everyone's a
lifestyle drinker you know they'll just
have a glass of wine they'll have a beer
no one drinks to like excess in any
capacity when me and my mates go out we
have like literally one or two beers we
all drive like it you know it doesn't
matter we all enjoy our point of IPA
that's it like we're done like there's
no drinking culture and often in my
friendship group would it change my
enjoyment and the level of escapism ever
so slightly but that's because alcohol
you know just relaxes your body and it
heightens things it doesn't ever impact
on my sleep so then allow it to like I
literally have a stop gauge like if I'm
in apartment someone said to what a
third beer like I'd literally just walk
out the door because I know what that
means for me so I don't think so but I
will explore and go deeper on that in
case I'm giving the answer that I want
to give yeah and again we loop back to
your discussion with from you and your
thorough
which is what is my truth right because
a lot of the time and we're kind of
going real matter with this for people
that are maybe a little bit more new to
behavior change but um in the in the
simplest way possible you don't
necessarily know what your brain what is
best for your body and also your brain
is really good at telling you lies that
you want to believe so a lot of the time
you will give yourself a reason which is
the first reason that comes to mind or
the most convenient reason that comes to
mind which is a proxy a very convenient
proxy for the truth super easy to
swallow doesn't actually ask you the
hard question and what you're doing
there is you're trying to unearth you're
trying to strip off all that ego get rid
of all that and say right okay no no
yeah that's been that's what the that's
the first answer you gave what's the
real answer that might be the same but
it might not and again for the people
who are listening this is something that
you should consider right are you giving
yourself the easy answer you're telling
yourself just what you want essentially
telling yourself what you want to hear
and then passing that offers the truth
being like AAA or if I know I want about
take it from the moment so again my main
point here is that you are the outlier
amongst most people's drinking habits
like if you were to say to people do you
spend more or less than thirty pounds a
month on average on alcohol
huge swathes of people are going to be
well above that 30 quid is like a round
of Yaga bombs in London you know like
and it's like one drink in New York I
was in New York a year ago today some
sad maybe you know I mean like it's the
financial thing big difference the fact
that you have your drinking under
control because you've got hard lines in
the ground so um let me just pivot for a
second that's a really good point
actually to give people some tacit
takeaways on how they can start control
their own drinking so first off if you
want to have a course it'll guide you
through six months sober calm slash
podcast will take you to everything that
we've spoken about but one of the
easiest ways to think about your
drinking habit is to do exactly what
Ben's done and to set what I call bright
lines known in behavior changes bright
lines and it is a rule that you stick to
no matter what and the reason that that
works especially well with alcohol is
that alcohol is what I've termed an
inhibition reduction echo-chamber it
means that every drink you have makes
not having a subsequent drink more
difficult we've all been there right one
drink turns into two turns into five
turns into a bottle of wine turns into a
kebab and a scrap at 3:00 in the morning
and wake up with a hangover and all that
stuff you know like the classic class
how do you know I was just going out I
just popped out you know like that
classic go like comedy sketch so like
the easiest solution for this is to do
what you've done and you've stumbled
upon what I consider someone who's
living in this space to be the most
effective way to control drinking if
you're not going to go totally sober I
still think that because of the health
effects because of the fact that it sets
you up for strong behavior change long
term and also because the two different
versions tend will almost always tend
toward the person that goes sober being
further ahead I still think that a
period of focus sobriety is good but if
you're just going to reduce then that's
the way to do it the way to do it is
that and you know I have to kind of the
elephant in the room is that I've seen a
million people going to my club nights
so I am both
judge jury executioner marketer and guy
stood on the front door of the
courthouse letting everybody in my
entire industry my business the house is
paid for by people coming to my club
nights and getting drunk and a lot of
the time people bring up a what they
might see as a little bit of a
contradiction and how can you be a club
promoter and also be an advocate for
productive sobriety or elective sobriety
as it's called well I don't have a
problem with people drinking I actually
think that it's a very important rite of
passage especially for young people you
know you need to know you're 20 years
old that people message all the time hey
bro love the podcasts 20 years old
thinking of doing six months sober what
do you think I'm like maybe did it like
the 28th day or the 90 day thing if you
want but being honest you probably still
got a lot to learn from being drunk you
need to know what it's like to have an
argument with your mate at 3 in the
morning and lose your keys in Manchester
like you need to know right because that
is a representative experience which
allows you to relate to people when
you're older like you will have
especially as someone who played sports
like when you were a uni and all this
awesome you'll have just endless numbers
of these stories and it's kind of it is
a rite of passage it's a par for the
course you kind of gotta have it right
now there's a more societal change
question where you could say well could
we get rid of alcohol altogether should
we potentially make it illegal if
alcohol was introduced today it would be
a Class A in terms of toxicity addiction
all that sort of stuff I mean that's
that's quite scary in itself but the
societal change thing it ain't happening
right once once something's got brought
in and the values have been reduced down
which they have they don't get taken
back so alcohols not going anywhere
we're not gonna have another was our
thing was I think in America where they
got rid of it all
yes prohibition so you need to drink
bizarrely actually to have like those
relatable experiences that take you
through later life my problem is seeing
someone who still drinks like a 20 year
old at 40 years old 50 years old because
all the work that they've done with mind
and body and spirit throughout the way
you know they've got themselves to the
gym they've just about got over there
hungover on a Monday from the weekend
and they've got themselves in the gym
and oh well I mean right and I'm doing
this tiny other and I made these
sacrifices right after the sacrifice
throughout the week I've worked hard and
he gets to Thursday and they're thinking
yeah yeah I'm gaining it I'm gaining my
I'm feeling better my mind's feeling
better I'm feeling fresh it gets to a
Friday and they think I've worked so
hard this week better reward myself with
two heavy nights out that reset all of
the progress and the sacrifices that I
made during this week and seeing someone
repeat that Kalin's for a decade or two
decades or three decades is a tragedy to
me like it makes me so sad man like
especially coming from I'm from
stockton-on-tees
so it's like them the arse end of
Middlesbrough which is you know hardly
like the most affluent area in the world
anyway and to see I just used to see
these these people who have so much
potential
right and who the [ __ ] you to judge
on what people choose to do with their
lives I'm like don't get me wrong like
people can choose to do whatever they
want but I don't think that's using I
think that they're taking the path of
least resistance which is just a groove
that's being cooked from when they were
a kid and then they've grown up and
they've never decided to deprogram this
this desire to drink
they've never decided are actually going
to see if I'm choosing to drink if I'm
just doing it because it's what people
do and um yeah man it makes me it makes
me sad you know it makes me sad that
we've got we've got a world where some
brilliant people could be a lot happier
if they hadn't continued to reset that
progress every single weekend with a
couple of heavy nights out and it's like
you get one shot at life at one shot to
get everything right to experience the
things you want to experience to be with
the people you want to be with and
you're choosing to take something and
it's not even enhancing the situation
like if you were to choose something I
don't even know what the drug would be
maybe I guess maybe like caffeine
perhaps that would make you more more
present more focused on to the obviously
not too much but alcohol actually
bizarrely it's memory loss it's nothing
your emotions its sedating you and
making you go asleep it's doing all of
these things and like it just to finish
this section here there's a concept
called the living with the edge and this
is this is something that's quite
interesting and this is actually coming
straight out of the six months sober
course so if you go through life leaning
on alcohol for support by using it to
make stressful times less bad and good
times more numb you will lead a life
completely void of edges now edges are
dangerous if you fall off them but
they're also the most exciting place to
be standing near the edge is when you
learn the most you make the most
memories looking back on your life
you'll find that you spend all your time
in the middle 50% of experience richness
that will be a very dull place to be so
some some things for you there so you
know I said I had three reasons I just
remembered the third now you've read
that out hit me so firstly I've always
had rules so part of this for me comes
down to what else people want to
experience in their lives when I was a
uni I went out three times a week
without fail at uni Monday night was
[ __ ] blind at night registered where
did you go to uni hull okay great
nightlife dead sheet anyway attic oh is
it attic yeah like a library ignite or
whatever when you were there yeah yeah
attic didn't go there much because it
was a bit more kind of like emo Rock
sort of a you know I've always been more
electronic Wednesday night sports team
so that again that was a right passage
less I've learnt girls girls girls
no regrets there and then Thursday night
was the big sort of dancing club get
dressed up have a good time but I've
always say to myself at 2:00 a.m. as
soon as I get that vibe the party's
dying off I'm out I used to walk home
with a liter of water because everywhere
was like 20-minute walk in how I used to
walk home of a liter of water grab
grilled chicken kebab on the way home
and then you do realize how
unrepresentative your relationship with
alcohol is though right like there's no
one listening that's going yeah yeah
that has me University everyone's going
what [ __ ] freak like no that's that's
not how people live their lives I my
point is if you create those rules you
can live between both extremes so I'd be
the guy that was up at 7 o'clock in the
morning I go to the gym then I go to uni
don't go and work on my business in the
afternoons uni but it was about making
those decisions before you entered into
the experience right like I'm going out
tonight but I'm going home by one I'm
having three drinks on you know whatever
those decisions are for you in your life
bright lights bright lights and I just
and it's because you know when I was
younger always read the books of people
that had seen and created success and
seen failure and they all had these
rules that everyone had some kind of
system that they had to live by to get
the output in their life that they
wanted um so the third reason was
actually memory so I love festivals I go
to at least two festivals every summer
absolutely lose my marbles have tons of
fun get cut when he when you tend to go
we quite often go to one local hospitals
son down in Norfolk it's got great dance
line up but I've been everywhere
Glastonbury dive into like probably I
went to Croatia last year was incredible
for day I don't stop I'm for hideout no
we went to hospitality records is first
alright oh yeah yeah telling is legit
and there's some good artists on that
label I'd love to get a hideout as well
anyway so I listened to a lot of drum
and bass so when I have a beer I'm
making dinner and I'm listening to those
Muse tunes that all come from the
festival I just get to spend 15 or 20
minutes reliving the
variance of the festival and I for me I
just get that moment where I remember
when we did that remember when he jumped
off that thing remember when you played
that track and I loved that experience
it gives you such a nice energy been out
to relive beautiful moments and your
everyday life why couldn't you do that
without the alcohol well I could I
definitely could it's just you kind of
get that relaxed Ness and you know just
you know just that moment escapism it's
that moment where you're actually like
all for a moment I feel like I'm drunk I
feel like I'm there I feel like I just
don't give a [ __ ] about anything okay so
here we go his bonus round
bonus round on reasons why I'm going to
try and convince you right the final one
is that by using alcohol to
sajin ously give you a sensation you
will never learn to be able to create it
yourself now that's not to say you've
just said that I could do it right but
alcohol just makes it a bit better it's
a-okay if you were forced to you're
sober for a period you would have to
learn to be able to recreate that
without the buttress of alcohol and it's
the same for the guy who can only go up
and talk to girls when he's absolutely
hammered right that was me that that
still mostly is me which is probably why
I'm single after 18 months or 20 months
of sobriety you know it's not it's not
I've got I've got a fantastic Instagram
game so but yeah like if that's a guy
who who has to have the alcohol to go up
and speak to the girl
if you don't ever go sober you will
never actually cultivate the ability to
go up and speak to the girl you will
never actually develop the confidence to
be able to talk in a group sat around a
table having dinner you will never be
able to you know people who drink to
have a difficult discussion with that
partner or people that drink to be able
to deal with the way that their boss
talks to them at work so that they can
relax on a nighttime or the stresses of
being young entrepreneur why did but
pick whatever it is for as long as you
use alcohol as your support system as
the scaffolding that's in there right
like you're never actually cultivating
what it is that you need to get through
that situation because you're just
relying on alcohol as the buttress now
again the challenge with you is that
it's a very holistic non destructive
reason of why you or why you're doing it
and it's not as if you're not doing it
because you've got a crazy aggression
that you need to chill out by that
because you just want to fight everybody
in the street or say you know some other
kind of malignant version of you it's
not that it's just a just adding a
flavor on top of reality but again with
all of these situations you can see how
those four areas that have taken us
through you know they're you are by far
in a way an anomaly for that to not be
one
that one of those things triggering and
going [ __ ] I'll actually may yeah but
I do you know what it is I do I do I do
do that because I just have a bad day at
work and I have to sink like three beers
on a night time or else I can't sleep or
I can't sleep unless I drink or you know
whatever it is pink pick your reason
from what we've gone through and this
isn't me trying to be like high and
mighty or any of that for the listeners
I want people to know that there is a
middle ground that ultimately has to
work for everyone and you have to be
happy and like you probed with me it's
like could we get any more positive
outcomes from you making changes and if
I can hand on heart say no I feel every
layer of my relationship with it is fine
then as a coach you would be happy with
that but if I then said actually yeah
[ __ ] that's when we need the
intervention that's when we need kind of
change and sometimes you have to go to
the extreme to find out where your
middle ground this and sometimes people
don't get that with self-development and
that's why I quite like going all in on
stuff like if I did feel I was having a
poor relationship I would be the guys go
cool I'll give up alcohol whatever like
because I want to see what's on the
others other side of that [ __ ] it's the
same with fitness like I've I've been at
the point where I've gone to the gym
everyday without fair for two hours a
day cardio core weights relentlessly
non-stop to know that I don't [ __ ]
want to do that actually just want to go
to the gym three days a week and that's
that's cool and so sometimes people have
to go to the extreme you have to have
the awareness to pull yourself out and
find where your own middle ground is
well what did we say at the beginning I
heard that we're way quote about
computer Confucian gentlemen right the
person who has to do the thing
consciously after D program what you're
doing unconsciously choose to do
something consciously and that actually
enables you to be spontaneous in a way
that's fully okay completely
internalized right it's you choosing to
drink choosing to drive from it like
it's actual core not only choosing to
drink but being able to give me like a
pretty robust breakdown of like why you
drink which for the vast majority of
people before this conversation that
might not have been the treat like are
you are you uncovering the reasons why
you do
the things that you do and that goes
from everything like why is it that you
get upset about the fact that your
partner doesn't text you back
immediately like that's a good question
too because you know this is a whole new
like whirlwind that we've we can decide
to jump into but you know why's that
or why is it that you always
catastrophize a situation or why is it
for the entrepreneurs that are listening
why is it that you have to work all of
the time and you are terrified of taking
a day off or that you feel like you
should always be progressing and always
be growing in your personal development
why is it that could it be deep down
that you don't feel like you're good
enough and that the only way that you
can get people to need you and to want
you and to become better is to
constantly be layering new skills and
new achievements and new accomplishments
on top of yourself you know and this is
what at the very very beginning when you
were talking about like is this my truth
this is the onion that we're talking
about when it comes to personal
development and behavior change right
it's like you strip away one thing or
you even like to cut a big fat segment
out of it you cut a wedge out of your
onion and you're like our card conquered
alcohol there did that six months sober
thing with brilliant you're right okay
you have got another 500 different areas
of your life precisely like alcohol that
you're going to have to jump into you're
gonna have to do your relationship with
your partner with your parents with your
friends oh and by the way what about
your health and your fitness and your
mindset and the way that you view your
body and the way they view you and you
just go and this is why it's a lifelong
thing and this is why I think that you
know trying to cultivate a growth
mindset as Carol Dweck would say to
continue to want to become better to do
all at source so I think it's it's the
one of the most important personality
traits that you're gonna get in the 21st
century and hope you know hopefully
today we've started to get people to
question some of their assumptions
around alcohol like why am i drinking is
it serving me and you know as a coping
mechanism especially now to finish up I
know you wait to mention this to do with
the quarantine like a lot of people
don't have much else going on they think
oh I'll make my night a bit more
exciting may my night a bit more
interesting
having a drink it's like well okay again
why why is your life not sufficiently
exciting without this exogenously
injection of alcohol of something to
make it more are we just helped me relax
well okay so you telling me that you
can't relax without alcohol well no no
no I don't mean that well it sounds like
that's what you're saying that's what
your actual answer is telling me write
your answers telling me I can't relax
your answers telling me that I can't
have fun without up and pick your thing
I can't deal with a global pandemic
without a drink you know like it's I
like the idea of an ascetic life a s CET
I see which is people that renounce
particular things I love the idea of an
ascetic life because it allows you to
see what you like without it you know
allows you to see and you mentioned this
about going all-in on things and Jordan
Peterson's got something about this as
well or he says about with young
entrepreneurs says it in your 20s you
should see if you can work 12 hours a
day six days a week you should you
should see if you can do it and then you
should see if you can do four hours a
day two days a week you should allow
your discomfort to be pulled in one
direction and pulled in another because
the type B person would find the first
situation a [ __ ] nightmare but a
type-a person like yourself if I said
Ben you're allowed to work eight hours
total next week it would kill you it
would turn you inside out you go oh god
hang in a second like this is really
challenging here so all of these
different things
relinquishing control of control
relinquishing control of working
relinquish in control of leisure of
alcohol of comfort food of a
relationship being on your own being
forced to be on your own all this sort
of thing each time you do this if you
view it as a situation you can learn
from okay yeah this sucks but what's the
lesson I've learned how much better and
how much more robust and resilient can I
be moving forward having had this
situation I'm like you know if you
cultivate that mindset nothing actually
becomes a problem it's just a particular
challenge that you need to find a
solution to and after you've found that
solution after you got through the other
side you have
a lesson you've learned and then that
lesson you can use again in the future
maybe this has been absolutely awesome
where can people find you I know you've
already mentioned it six months sober
six months sober calm slash podcast if
you're interested in that modern wisdom
is the podcast so check it out if you
enjoy sort of things I'm talking about
here I have far more interesting and
well educate people than me doing the
same thing just read pilling me daily on
the podcast within three episodes a week
at the moment so yes sir just by fire or
podcasts all that stuff for at Chris
will X wherever you go online and that's
pretty much it I think that's that's
everything man thank you so much for
having me back on dude oh yeah I really
appreciate it again I have to say like
the opportunity that you gave me
whenever it was you're in a bit ago a
couple years ago when we first started
recording it made a big difference to
the podcast so I've got a lot to thank
you for he's great he's deep its deep
like that there's some there I did one
with a porn star I did one with a girl
that started at Miami dot VIP and I
recently did one with a man that spent a
million pounds on drugs so you are right
there's some intellectual ones but every
so often you can just find out oh I'll
be the one with a porn star with the guy
that spent a million quid on drugs but
you are right there's some there's some
that go they go fairly deep but that's
good if people want that that's exactly
the place to go and yeah mate big
support big fan and I'm always grateful
to speak to you because I just there's a
lot of exploration that our own mind
well my own mind wants to have with each
other and I think that's a good thing
and I'm more than happy to be challenged
on any of my [ __ ] [ __ ] because if I
don't choose to challenge it I don't
grow and you know people might sometimes
think it's almost a self-serving thing
well partly is because it's my podcast
and it's my exploration of health and
fitness so I get to make the [ __ ]
rules second thing is if people follow
it's the right level of context so if
you listened to me last week and you
listened to me next week you get to hear
the journey you get to hear the gaps you
get to hear the king
and I get to constantly paint this
picture where you can see what I'm
trying to work through because otherwise
you don't allow yourself to really
understand who I am and what I'm working
through through the podcast and through
the experts and stuff and also I need to
be vulnerable for everyone else to be
vulnerable you need to be vulnerable for
the people that are going through your
program to be vulnerable without
vulnerability we don't grow so what
you've talked about today is going to
make a lot of people uncomfortable it's
going to make them vulnerable to the
future to themselves you've got a you've
got to embrace that and I think this is
why I often say we don't need to
celebrate and broadcast every front
online because whatever change you want
to make can be very personal but if you
want to go and do chris's program then
you don't have to announce it to the
world you don't even have to tell your
girlfriend if you don't want to for now
just you know log on you know watch the
first video and just be like I'm just
gonna have a look at this I'm just gonna
challenge it and then when you feel more
confident you can then start to share
things with the world and we do get into
a bit of a habit of like I'm starting
you diet I'll post it on character on
Facebook and then Karen gets involved
and surely get some [ __ ] Bowl and
then everyone's already feeling judged
because they put it out on social media
so no one needs to be involved in this
stuff if it just needs to be your
journey with yourself for now so take
kind of comfort in that but Chris thanks
again for your wisdom legend brother
thank you so much thank you to everyone
that's tuned in I think the synopsis
thought you just said there was like you
know you need to see me last week and
you need to see me next week I think the
synopsis to that is press subscribe to
Ben khumba Radium hopefully they're
already subscribed Jesus man I keep on
getting I can see the back end I listen
to podcast you think I can't see you on
the back end I can see you on the back
end an Apple podcast connects metric and
I can see how many people are subscribed
now how many artists 30% if you didn't
still need to hit the button and you
just you just get it delivered on you
just check in when you choose to check
and swipe it up no go press the button
thank you boo right people if you have
enjoyed this podcast please share it
around send it to a friend raised
discussion around it reach out to Kris
give him a high-five say hello to him is
a great guy if you want to see a good
rig then you you know you you're better
off going to see Chris's in Spanish you
are not getting a good rig on on my
Instagram but I'll be honest I'm doing
half decent on the dad bones phone bro
you are you're in a tolling you leave
now and you have a total total new
league at least I get to bring out the
dad bod program at some point which
everyone does that would be that would
be sick but I'm not gonna do it so I
train Chris legend everyone listening
all that leads me to say let's go and
have an awesome day
goodbye
[Music]
you